lotto tippgemeinschaft fast 200 jahren
obligatorisch ist die gesellschaft
bestens order identität utopie
katholisches worden ist dass die
jugendlichen nach inneren glut einer
show of pop
das bietet wenn die vom fonds cooling
leasing die familie rommel familie liebe
familie freund- und wenn die jungs
familie und das ist ideal daten bezogen
genau die gleiche situation vor der
schule bringt auf negative nachrichten
zum beispiel als auslands auf gott oder
fuhren weg sonst schläft die sache zwei
freundinnen zwei lebensentwürfe
amanda ist homeschooling ihre freundin
magdalena geht in die schule
ja so kollegin aber empfehlen darum
wirklich schnell
doch damit ist klar ich hole klaus
kommen und die famitsu klingt zwar immer
noch viel kontakt mit ihnen und auch in
anh hung schools das ist wirklich im
freiraum in der stadt bern treffen sich
holmes kohle aus dem ganzen kanton
[Musik]
[Applaus]
theoretisch so wichtig große bedeutung
für optimale sozialisation nicht
unbedingt in ruhe bringen
[Musik]